um nothing can immediate futurale and it
should be
thank you we're live leader
thank you very much welcome everyone to
the meeting of the northeast derbyshire
district council cabinet
uh it's the 8th of october at 4 30.
we'll get started uh straight away so
uh firstly do we have any apologies for
absence
i believe we have councillor parking who
is running late and should be joining
the meeting
uh as soon as he's able to get here are
there any others
non-received chair thank you alan okay
uh are there any uh declarations of
interest that any members wish to
declare
no okay thank you
and then in terms of the minutes of the
last meeting pages 5-13 of the
of the pack um have we all uh read them
and can we confirm them as a true and
accurate record i'm happy to move them
i'll second them thank you thank you all
those in favor
brilliant thank you very much uh and
then the next item
is the business centers and industrial
units uh
scrutiny review so we have i think uh
did see councilman is kept for
hutchinson present
where is he he was he's gone does he uh
he said he had that unstable
um internet so he may actually have just
lost him
okay uh shall we
are we able to amend the agenda just to
give them an opportunity to come back in
we are going to take the next report
first if that's okay everyone's happy
with that
uh so we'll we'll give anthony
opportunity to come back in
so we'll do the choice based i think
he's just come back in chair now
hold up okay
i'll wait wait for him to connect you
know audio
hi anthony are you i'm sorry that's all
right no problem we just got to your
report so if you're
uh if you're happy to just uh give us a
brief overview
yeah sure i mean i've put one two bits
together um
thanks for inviting me first of all um
in your papers you'll have a copy of the
report of the committee's findings
conclusions and recommendations
of its review of business centres and
industrial units
this is a report written approximately
two years ago and under a different
administration
that's not to take anything away from it
as i'm sure
that a lot of our work and debate went
into pushing it together by both
committee
members and of course our very competent
officers
uh particularly sue vehement currently
we're in the grip of this
business debilitating pandemic which is
changing the way we work
and play for that matter uh like i said
this is not a report i have been
involved in
but i understand uh councillor culpit
the cooper sorry and
councillor powell were both part of the
committee at the time so maybe they
they have got some some feelings on the
matter
um within the recommendations to my mind
there's nothing
particularly controversial uh and each
recommendation seems to have a
good business practice or just good
common sense
and it's important to all businesses to
constantly analyze the condition of its
operations
but under today's conditions that is
during a pandemic and post-pandemic the
council would have to decide if
in this if his industry is in decline
and would it be wise to create
more industrial units or actually
consolidate what they've got
so there's not much more to say about it
really and it's
it's something i'm i haven't
particularly been involved in i've
looked through it
and there's nothing massively
controversial in there
i'm sure you've already read it through
yeah thanks anthony yeah um i
agree with you on the recommendations
they're all uh common sense
things i think the report is is useful
uh in highlighting some
some areas that we can that we can
improve things
um i'll bring uh council powell in
uh yeah just to say that i was actually
involved in that scrutiny committee two
years ago
um and um we did a lot of um
visits and we heard a lot of evidence
and i'm
i'm happy to support the um the
recommendations and that we should note
them thanks thanks alan
uh carolyn
yeah i'd like to second councillor
paul's recommendations i also
as as as a very previous gross brutally
chair
had a lot of opportunity to look at the
report and i think a lot of
recommendations
have been carried out or are being
carried out and
um of course under my roommate now we
are actually pursuing
uh other queries and um development
on these industrial units anyway
brilliant thanks thanks carolyn so we
have a
a mover and a second are we all uh
are we all in favor please raise your
hand thank you
okay lovely that's that's carrie so um
so uh the the report is noted and the
recommendations obviously be picked up
by the
by the officer team and move forward
thank you very much anthony you you're
very welcome to stay
uh for us the meeting if you like or if
you want to get off that's that's
equally fine
thanks alex yeah i'm gonna get off if
that's okay
see you soon bye bye thank you bye
uh so next we come to the choice-based
lettings and allocation policy so over
to you council
right this is our report that is uh
updated annually
and it should have come forward in april
of this year but because of pandemic it
was delayed
um and it's due to be reviewed again in
march next year
there are one or two tweaks to it the
ones i would mention
are um moves to move us in line with the
armed forces government that we
signed recently and and the other is to
um
remove the equity level um
which has caused problems in the past
and we can now move to a situation where
we look at each um
each case on merit so um on that basis
uh chair i would like to uh move we
adopt the report
um and um and move forward with it
thanks i'm happy to second uh
karen do you want to come in or is that
just a second okay no that's fine
i'm happy to second is there any
comments before we move to the vote
no okay all those in favor
brilliant that's carried thank you very
much uh
and then we come to the clay crosstown
emerging investment plan so over to you
council running
thank you thank you um as you're aware
the clay crosstown investment plan is
moving at pace
and we have to submit the time
investment plan uh by the deadline 30th
of october
this is just a stage one of a number of
stages this is just the
basic outline of some of the plans it's
been through a significant check-in
challenge
and as you're aware this is actually run
by the the clay crosstown board which
sits separately to
this cabinet so really this is just to
and i know we've all had a good chance
to look at
in detail the uh draft tip
and i just would like really to
move that we accept the recommendations
6.16.3
and giving our unconditional support and
endorsement
for this project a very exciting project
for clay cross
thanks uh council relic i'm happy to
second again and obviously welcome
uh the the huge progress that's been
made by the
by the town board so thank you to all
those who were involved in the town
board and
our members and officers who have also
been doing a lot of the supportive work
because it really has come on
uh leaps and bounds over the past um
over the past few months
um so yeah well done tour involved um
any any comments on the
on the report itself obviously it's
going to uh
the town board tomorrow for sort of
final uh approval anyway
um and there may be still a further
opportunity to make the opportunity to
make further
final tweaks for a few days thereafter
but uh we're getting ready to obviously
submit it
by the end of this month so um is
everyone
everyone happy all those in favor
yeah brilliant thank you very much okay
and then we come to um
the medium term financial plan revised
budgets and conscious council powell
hasn't yet uh been able to make it to
the meeting are you okay to talk us
through this
uh jane i certainly i'm sure yes i can
do that for him
and this is to present you the medium
tim i've got the sunshine in my eyes i
do apologize
i've got the medium term financial plan
for the revised budget for 2021. so the
purpose of this report is to bring the
revisions to cabinet
for their consideration this will then
form part of the mpts
the refresh that will go to council for
approval along with the forward plan
of 2122 onwards
the provost revisions in the general
fund are detailed in appendix 1 and then
appendix 2 provides the breakdown by
service
of all the individual bad directors
sorry of all the individual services
as i've been reporting throughout the
year the kodi 19 pandemics obviously
having an impact on these budgets and
the big impact is on lost fees and
charges
predominantly through the leisure
centres but also in areas such as mot
testing and commercial waste collection
we have received government grants um
we've received 1.166 million in
government grants
and in addition to that i made the first
claim last week in
against the income compensation scheme
that the government have launched
which will compensate us for a
proportion of the income that we're
going to lose
from services such as leisure that claim
actually totaled 300
000 for the first four months of the
year that's april to july
and that was after the five percent top
slice which is the
amount that we have to stand from our
annual budget
so so as you can see it's gonna make
quite a difference to us if we if we get
three hundred thousand every
every three months every four months
that's another million pound that we're
getting towards the support that we need
for leisure
i've transferred all of the grants that
we've had thus far into the resilience
reserve and i'm releasing them as we
need them
back into the services because i wasn't
going to get
the i didn't know about the income
compensation scheme when i pulled the
budget together so we had to fund it
from the grant
so i will be doing a little bit of
teaming and lading with all of that but
it will it will shake out by the end of
the year and we'll see what we've
actually got available
so if i can just draw your attention to
table one that will become a little bit
clearer there
what i've tried to do there is
demonstrate that in the original budget
um we only planned to put 20 000 pounds
into reserves
and withdraw 258 from reserves that's
not unusual and this position does move
particularly with revenue grants as they
come in through the year and then we
release them back out through the year
but the movement this year is quite
startling in that we need to take
um 1.9 million out of reserves basically
to fund the coveted position
1.4 million of that is funded from from
monies that we've had in
and you can see the bottom line
demonstrates there that the kovid
related impact
is 1.166 into reserves which is what i
spoke about earlier
and 1.325 out so as at the point of
doing this report we had got a
small shortfall of 200k but that's now
going to be met by the
um inc compensation scheme so we're in a
position to balance the budget for 2021.
what i've done in table two is i've
pulled out all the key variances that
that relate to this budget and it is as
we've already talked about it's
predominantly the income reductions it's
leisure mot testing
commercial waste etc etc and then the
second part of the table shows where
we've actually taken
savings from within the budget somewhere
which we would take as a matter of
course and then others which we've taken
as a result of doing the emergency
budget back in back in may
so the overall position is that we've
got the 1.325 which is what i've just
discussed that we're going to be funding
from reserves
now this does give us a balanced budget
position which is a great
place to be in considering the
circumstances that we're actually
operating during this year but
since writing this report and today
things are moving so quickly that
that this constant pull on that reserve
so so for example we've got the
um emergency response team that we need
to now put in place for compliance and
enforcement that our environment
health team are going to lead on and
and that brings with it a cost i mean
these are short-term costs but it brings
with it a cost and that will be a draw
off the reserve so
i am expecting this to be able to
balance the budget but i don't think
there'll be a deal left
in a nutshell for me the bigger pressure
is going to be setting the mtfp for 21
22 onwards we've had an enormous amount
of government support this year it's
kept
it's allowed us to be in this position
but we have to be realistic and that's
probably not going to continue into
future years
we're still unclear what the
government's position is going to be
with regards to all of the
proposed changes as regards the
comprehensive spending assessment and
the
fair funding review i'm pretty confident
they're going to leave everything alone
for the next couple of years but
but we just have to have off an eye on
that as well so so i think it's going to
be
a challenge pulling the mtfp together um
but i will be speaking to you all about
that later
on bringing the no doubt not such good
news probably in december
or or january in terms of the
housing revenue account it's been
relatively settled to be fair
the housing revenue account hasn't been
anywhere near as badly impacted
as the is the general fund although we
have taken a little bit of a hit on
income because
an unintended consequence was we we move
rents
to what we call target rent which is the
which is the restructured rent level
um from where it was originally when
they become void we do that at that
point because it means the tenant
doesn't get affected
during the year um or the the incoming
tenant
pays a rent that they weren't familiar
with
and and that's actually lost us quite a
little bit of revenue but
it's a huge budget the housing revenue
income budget it's 32 million so
it's still only one percent off off
where it was before so i'm not overly
concerned about that
in terms of the capital programme i
think as we've spoken numerous times
before
we did pause the capital program because
we were concerned about cash flow
and the issues with cash flow haven't
materialized due to a number of reasons
we have been able to keep a fairly
static position
and so we've been able to release the
capital programme and it's back up and
running
and we're trying to recover where we
were i don't think we'll get 100 there
but we'll certainly make really good
inroads into it
for the front before lockdown so at that
point chair i'm happy to take any
questions before you move the
recommendations
thanks james and thank you for all the
work you've been doing on on the budget
i know it's been a
a turbulent year as far as the budget is
concerned but
it's pleasing to know as you say due to
significant
government grant this year we are um
probably going to be able to balance the
budget
this year and i think you're absolutely
right that it's the future years that
are of
most concern and where we need to be
most careful
i've just got one question before i open
it out to um
to colleagues the you mentioned the the
um
loss of income compensation scheme and
the first
um application for that was to cover the
first
presumably the first few months i think
he said the first three or four months
of the financial year
obviously that was a period where the
leisure centers were mostly closed
so presumably for the next uh the next
period that we
that we make that claim for the amount
that we would claim would be a lot less
on the basis that the legislators
are open is that is that right that's
that's absolutely right
the only the only positive element that
we're going to have in the future claims
is that we've already had
the the five percent so we can claim 95
and we've already taken the hit on the 5
in the first claim
so you're absolutely right the first
claim would be the biggest but has been
reduced the most
so it may soften a little bit but yeah
you're absolutely right it will be lower
in future months
right okay okay thank you for that and
any um any other colleagues want to come
in jeremy
councillor kenyon yes thank you chad um
two questions
one you mentioned um that we would have
to do extra enforcement
for uh kobe 19 safety and so on
uh has there been any sign of any um
offer for
extra funding from the government to do
that and second questions about
the the following year which is uh
if if um income comes back up to normal
from on the first of april 2021 onwards
or at least with laser center and other
things do are there any other things
that would lead us to
to have a shortfall in that year or is
it just that loss of income
if it happened there was a lot of income
thank you councillor kenya i'll take the
first one first because that was a nice
easy one funnily enough we've literally
just this afternoon had an announcement
that there is going to be some
additional funding made available
i'm just waiting for confirmation from
mhclg as to how much that is going to be
but there is going to be some additional
funding made available
nationally this is not specific to
northeast derbyshire or anything to do
with local restrictions
this is um 30 million pounds being made
available across the
across the country so as soon as i know
how much that is i will let you all know
but that is that is indeed comforting
because that will cover off
the extra work that that ken and his
team are going to have to do as a result
of
of the measures we have to put in place
in answer to your second question um
how long is a piece of string if i got a
crystal ball it would it would have lots
of things floating around in there at
the moment
my big concern last year when i was
setting the mtfp was what are the
government government going to do with
the comprehensive spending assessment
and we were all talking about
losing new homes bonus we were talking
about um the fair funding review
business rates reset all of those things
are still
kicking around in the background none of
them have gone away
um but i think from what i'm from what
i'm hearing i think what they're going
to do is just let the just
settle on um we're all going to have a
mountain to climb next year
um and pretty much a straw poll of all
the local authorities across the country
and they're all saying they're going to
have to use reserves to balance the
budget next year so
i would expect and hope that it will be
a
rollover of the existing funding
mechanism so all we've got to worry
about is covid next year
and then bring on 22 23 when um when the
fun can start again with the
with the comprehensive spending review
thank you jane thanks sir kenny i'm
happy to uh are there any further
questions before we move on
uh mark uh council foster yeah uh
thanks chair uh just a quick one uh on
table two the income reductions leisure
uh
1.6 million uh percentage-wise
if we know uh off if you know off the
top you have percentage wise how much
are we down this last month
uh under current operating um
uh the operating situation due to kovid
as we would normally be
uh this time of year so just roughly
what is the income reduced by on the
leisure side
we're running it about 75 at the moment
council foster it was
it was 60 to start with and it's
creeping up and we're hoping no
we're at about 70 sorry and we're hoping
to get to 75
over the next couple of months we don't
think we'll get any higher than 75
with the existing restrictions that we
have to put in place
so we came in at 60 and we're on that
upward curve towards 75
and we're at 70 at the moment sorry that
was a little bit unclear sorry
thanks for that i appreciate it
just to add to that uh yes what jane
said sir
spot on um we are i've just started a
conversation with
leicester about uh increasing our
promotion of it because
even while obviously at peak times it is
it's a capacity and
there are off-peak times when when it's
still got lots of capacity
so uh looking to whether we could
increase that that's the conversation
has literally just started though
brilliant thank you councillor kenyon um
i'm happy to move the recommendations
which are effectively that we
uh recommend to full council the next
four councillors presumably that's going
to the november
meeting um jane is that the intention it
will go to the february's meeting as
part of the mtfp we normally take the
revised budget at the
february meeting so it just gets rolled
in as part of the whole budget process
sorry chair i should have made that
clearer in the report no that's fine
okay well i'm happy to
have to move that um counselor relic
yeah i'm just happy to second that as
well and to thank jane
and her team i know things have been
moving very really quickly and
you have always kept up to speed you all
seem like you're head of the game i
really really appreciate that
i know you know i i truly believe that
some of the
areas of the spend that we've agreed
recently
are really important in terms of
operational function of this council
and um the only caveat is obviously
as um lockdown two might be coming our
way
and the fact that fellow finishes for
many people end of this month things
might look different so
you know steady as she goes and i know
you've got that in mind but thank you
very much to all of you
for keeping us up to speed absolutely
thank you council running and okay those
i think would all echo those
those comments uh all those in favor
brilliant thank you that's carried and
then getting back to the agenda
i think we're on to urgent items
of which uh i have none
and then i will move the public be
excluded from the meeting
during the discussion of the following
items of business to avoid the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as defined in part one
schedule 12a of the local government act
1972
uh now that's it i think uh
can we just have confirmation that the
live stream has has finished whenever
you're ready
you